my bachelor fans those are my favorite  we thought they were our favorites too  but that was before we saw kaley cuoco  'he's newest pair of leggings The  Bachelor superfan took her obsession one  step further on Monday debuting these  glorious pants on Instagram that were  perfect for the dating show season  finale there's Lauren B there's Jojo and  a whole bunch of question marks epic is  really the only word that comes to mind  posing side-by-side with her younger  sister Brianna the 30 year old wrote in  the caption who's it gonna be before the  winner Lauren B was revealed on TV  equally impressive as Kaylee's pants her  fit physique the Big Bang Theory star  opened up to each he last month about  the secret behind her killer bod yoga is  the secret yoga is the reason I have  been yeah it's done everything mentally  and physically I love it